I think we've always thought that
they're the best dads and the animal
kingdom right because they get pregnant
they nurture the offspring and what our
study shows is that it kind of has this
dark side
most fish such as the ones we see here
in the London Aquarium reproduce in the
old-fashioned way
males produce a lot of sperm which are
very cheap to produce and females
produce a few eggs that are rather
expensive to produce and that means the
females are more choosy about the males
with whom they reproduce now seahorses
and pipefish are unique in that it's a
complete reversal it's the male's who
get to do the choosing because they
incubate the eggs they are pregnant and
it's the only case of male pregnancy we
have male pregnancy which occurs in
signified fish is when a seahorse or
pipe fish carries their offspring in
what we call the brood pouch which is a
chamber on the outside of his body
females transfer eggs into those brood
patches during mating the male
fertilizes the eggs within the breed
pouch and then the male carries the
offspring will they develop and finally
a couple of weeks later they're born as
free swimming offspring when Kimberly
and Adam were looking at the gulf pipe
fish they wanted to know the degree to
which the males were actually
controlling the state of play is the
pouch in a pipe fish simply a pocket in
which you can park baby the pipe fish as
they develop or is it taking a much more
active and perhaps rather sinister role
in the raising of their young
the study of sexual selection is
increasingly important in evolutionary
biology it's actually quite a hot topic
Darwin realized how important it was as
a kind of handmaiden to natural
selection that as well as the classic
natural selection in which the most
suited to the environment will survive
and and preferentially breed there was
also this complex interplay between the
sexes because males and females invest
differently in the young when Darwin
proposed the theory of sexual selection
he dealt entirely with pre-meeting
sexual selection so he was talking about
pre-meeting choice and pre meeting
combat for access to females and so so
the idea is that males are competing for
females and you'll get the evolution of
things like antlers on deer and the
Peacocks tail and all these kinds of
classic examples the results of sexual
selection but there's a part that Darwin
left out and that was post mating sexual
selection so it turns out that after
mating there are things that happen
within the females reproductive tract or
competition among sperm from different
different males or something like that
that also results in sexual selection
this is what we're trying to study so it
turns out that post mating sexual
selection has hardly been studied at all
in these sex-role reversed species like
we work in we find pipefish they occur
in the Gulf of Mexico and they occur in
shallow seagrass meadows and they turn
out to be really easy to catch right
because they're really abundant and
they're actually not very good swimmers
then we can catch lots of fish bring
them back to the lab keep them alive in
the lab and do our experiments there
Gulf pipe fish make an excellent system
for this particular experiment because
we can observe the eggs directly through
the pouch during the entire
you see here's his head his pouch is
down here this is the seam between the
flaps and you can see how the eggs would
sit underneath of that flap there for
this experiment what we did was we mated
the males with several females we picked
either large or small females for each
mail if females actually managed to mate
with a male they have to transfer this
egg to to the male's brood pouch and
then hope that that male actually invest
the resources that are necessary for the
ink to survive once we saw that they had
made it we looked into the brood pouch
using a dissecting microscope with a
camera and we took a photograph of the
brood at the beginning of the middle and
the end
so first the egg right after the females
transferred it here which is yellow now
but would ordinarily be reddish orange
then one week later you get this stage
it's pretty small still this would
ordinarily still have a yolk on it but
it's fallen off on this specimen and
then here you have an embryo that's just
about ready to be born so it's quite a
bit larger the snouts longer the eyes
are bigger it's about ready to be an
independent juvenile the brood patch is
transparent and the eggs are large so
you can actually photograph the brood
pouch right after the eggs are
transferred and keep track of them
throughout the entire pregnancy so you
know for every single egg that's
transferred whether it actually resulted
in an offspring at the end of the
pregnancy but what we also see is some
eggs that never develop so those will
not show any sign of the embryo tissue
and they'll even sort of shrink and
change in color over the course of the
pregnancy then once the male had given
birth to that first brood we paired him
with a second female again either small
or large and we did the same thing again
and so then we could contrast a males
first pregnancy to his second Prince
I think we've always thought of the
brood pouch as being a structure that
evolved to nurture the offspring right
so the idea is that they're the best
dads in the animal kingdom right because
they get pregnant they nurture the
offspring they're transferring nutrients
and they're protecting the offspring and
what our study shows is that that can
happen but sometimes that doesn't happen
sometimes it looks like the male with
holds resources from the offspring and
sometimes evidence suggests that the
males can even absorb resources from the
offspring and so it suggests another
role for the brood patch so instead of
just being sort of the ultimate
nurturing great structure it kind of has
this dark side
if you picture the male looking for a
mate and he's not meeting a lot of
females and so he decides well maybe it
would be better to mate with this
smaller female she's not the most
attractive female but she's here when
the male mates with a female that's not
necessarily that attractive instead of
investing a lot in those offspring he's
kind of recharging for the next
pregnancy hour at least this is what our
results suggest and he's kind of
absorbed absorbing nutrients are
withholding nutrients from that brood so
that he's ready when he gets a more
attractive mate to invest more and that
particular females offspring I think we
are filling in a big gap because I think
it's really significant that Darwin left
this whole big part of sexual selection
out I mean it's critical there are
critical things happening after mating
and there are things that we don't
really understand I have a lot of papers
about the evolution of sex and sexual
selection and this paper I thought was
really neat because what he did was
supply a test of the whole idea of
sexual selection by showing that it
wasn't the fact that some animals were
male and some animals were female that
controlled the process it didn't matter
which gender was which and here we have
a wonderful natural system in which the
roles are naturally reversed and it
allows you to show that sexiest
selection happens just the same
underpinning Darwin's idea of them you
know 150 years ago and that I think is a
very satisfying conclusion
you
you